what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and today we have more
around the rumors of the fantastic
forecasting and there have been a lot of
rumors going around a lot of speculation
going around since doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness has come out and
if you have not seen doctor strange 2
yet here's your spoiler warning we are
going to be talking about spoilers
specifically obviously if you're still
here you know the illuminati john
krasinski showed up as mr fantastic reed
richards of the fantastic four in doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness and
since then and honestly way before then
rumors have been going crazy there's a
lot of rumors and speculation out there
about who the actual cast of the
fantastic four could be and this is
actually kind of cool because if we
think about this for a second john
krasinski was kind of a fan cast as mr
fantastic the fans really really wanted
him and then people started drawing
pictures of him as mr fantastic and
doing art of him and then eventually we
got him on screen as mr fantastic in the
illuminati now hopefully he does play
the main mcu's reed richards but we'll
unfortunately have to wait and see on
that however today we have some
developments on the invisible woman who
everybody really hopes is played by john
krasinski's wife emily blunt however
there was a report going around under a
couple of weeks ago that bryce dallas
howard had been cast to play sue storm
there was also the rumor that she was
going to be directing the film or
producing it as well alongside of john
krasinski well bryce has reacted to
these rumors so let's go ahead and check
out her reaction and talk about what it
means and of course if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest news
[Music]
so like i just mentioned the report and
rumors going around were that bryce
dallas howard had been cast as sue storm
slash the invisible woman now keep in
mind bryce has many connections with
disney her father ron howard is a
massive part of star wars she herself
directed episodes of the mandalorian and
probably one of the best episodes of the
book of boba fett so she's already
worked with disney plus not to mention
her co-star for the jurassic world
movies is chris pratt so i'm sure
there's a lot going for her with disney
disney seems to love her if they invited
her to direct a book of boba fett
episode after the two mandalorian
episodes that she directed and other
people who are majorly involved with
disney love her but as you can see in
this video she is denying that she is
not playing the invisible woman in the
upcoming fantastic four movie in the mcu
now there's two parts to this one is
that i actually think she would do a
great job as sue storm i know a lot of
people are saying that she needs to lose
weight for the role but actors and
actresses do that all the time for roles
and honestly she'd be fine the way she
is but the second thing is that i
actually wouldn't mind if she is not the
invisible woman because i would really
love for emily blunt to play the
invisible woman i just think the idea of
having a husband and wife in real life
john krasinski and emily blunt playing a
husband and wife in the movie reed
richards and sue storm would be really
cool i also think that emily blunt
really really fits the role as sue storm
i mean all of the fan art of john
krasinski looked fantastic and then when
we saw him on screen he looked fantastic
pun intended and i'm sure it's going to
be exactly the same for his wife emily
blunt we've all seen the fan art of her
she looks again fantastic as a member of
the fantastic four and here's the deal
they have at least talked to emily blunt
about this there's zero chance that they
haven't talked to her about this because
i mean her husband was just mr fantastic
and is probably going to continue to be
the main mr fantastic so they have
absolutely had these talks and i'm sure
they would think it would be pretty cool
to play a husband and wife role in a
movie as well now here's the deal can we
trust bryce dallas howard when she says
she is not playing the invisible woman
no
at no fault to her own but we can't
trust her because obviously if she is
going to be playing the invisible woman
she just can't announce that if we've
learned anything from andrew garfield in
spider-man no way home and let's face it
a bunch of other mcu actors as well it's
that you can't really trust them when
they say they're not in a movie now of
course sometimes these reports and
rumors are wrong and these actors aren't
in movies sure that happens but the
point is you can't really trust an
actor's word when they say they're not
in an mcu film so yes bryce dallas
howard has denied being involved in the
fantastic four or playing sue storm but
we don't really know still this does not
mean that she is not playing sue storm
and you should remember that however at
the same time if she's not i think fans
will be okay with it because i think
fans really want emily blunt to play sue
storm but let me know what you think
about this in the comments down below
who would you like to play mr fantastic
sue storm the thing and the human torch
in the mcu's fantastic four let me know
down below don't forget to like this
video and of course for live updates you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
i'm currently at star wars celebration
so if you want live updates be sure to
follow me and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof